nvidia is back with a new Android shield
now based on its powerful Tegra x1 chip
this slim 200 our box runs on the
android TV operating system offering the
usual content like controller optimized
android games and media apps but nvidia
has other tricks up its sleeve gaming is
central to the shield so Nvidia is going
the extra mile to deliver content that
can't be found on other android boxes
Nvidia secret sauce is the Tegra x1 and
it's working with publishers to deliver
console and PC grade content beyond
native android gaming you can stream
games from your PC like past shield
devices but the most important gaming
feature is shields ability to stream PC
games from in videos GTX 980 glazed
servers offering high end pc gaming on a
two-hundred-dollar box at least visually
that outpaces playstation 4 and xbox one
nvidia is also incentivizing people by
upgrading its grid service in the past
it would stream video at 720p and 30
frames per second but now grid can
support 1080p and 60 frames per second
while streaming to the new shield and
other shield devices I tested the
service on a consumer-grade comcast
internet connection and it was hands
down the best example of cloud game
streaming I've ever tried because the
games are running on a high-end GPU they
look amazing with minimal video
compression artifacts getting in the way
I played a combination of games
including grid 2 dying light ultra
street fighter 4 and metal gear solid 5
ground zeroes and Walter we're
perceptible latency issues on occasion
it only bothered me was street fighter 4
everything felt close to if not the same
as playing on a console I'll be it with
much better graphics new media's new
shield will cost around two hundred
dollars when it comes out hopefully
before summer a subscription model will
give you access to about 200 games as
well which is supposed to be priced
competitively with PlayStation Plus on
xbox live while you will have to pay
full price for new games that come to
grid nvidia is in negotiations with
valve to offer steam versions of games
with every grid purchase Nvidia may not
call it a console but let's be frank the
shield is a box that connects to your TV
plays the latest games for big
publishers and comes with a wireless
controller that sounds like a console to
me plus at two hundred dollars it may
give Sony and Microsoft a run for their
money if grid works is good in the real
world as it did during my demo time will
tell but one thing's for sure the future
of console gaming just got a lot more
interesting